[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans le journal de tv 78 voici les
titres de ce vendredi 4 décembre
justement ce vendredi c'est le coup
d'envoi de la mobilisation annuelle pour
le téléthon tout le week-end des
animations sont organisées à saint
quentin en yvelines crise sanitaire
oblige la plupart sont en ligne nous
parlerons également du téléthon avec
notre invité jus lynch est atteinte
d'une maladie neuromusculaire et futurs
coordinatrice du téléthon est dans les
yvelines dans l'actualité également
sophie cluzel secrétaire d'état a visité
le château de versailles jeudi 3
décembre à l'occasion de la journée
internationale des personnes handicapées
retour sur son déplacement enfin dans
l'actualité sportive au dernier pointage
l'yvelinois louis burton est remontée au
classement du vendée globe
il est désormais 2e comme chaque semaine
nous ferons le point sur son parcours
[Musique]
pour parler de ce week-end de
mobilisation pour le téléthon 2020 un
peu particulier forcément nous
accueillons juliusz et bonsoir
alors vous êtes atteinte d'une maladie
neuromusculaire qu'on appelle charcot
marie tooth c'est bien ça et vous êtes
la prochaine coordinatrice du téléthon
donc dans les yvelines est en
remplacement de monsieur bazin c'est ça
tout à fait alors juste avant vous poser
quelques questions ces animations sont
prévues durant tout le week end sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
pour cette 34ème édition du téléthon
tout au long de l'entretien avec julie
boucher nous donnerons quelques exemples
et on commence par magny les hameaux
alors la municipalité et l'association
au tm organise plusieurs points de
collecte de dons ce samedi 4 et ce
dimanche 5 décembre des urnes ont été
mises à disposition par exemple celle
devant l'hôtel de ville va rester
jusqu'au 11 décembre prochain je
rappelle donc que l'an passé le téléthon
2010 9 avait récolté plus de 87 millions
d'euros cette année beaucoup
d'événements sont annulés à cause de la
crise sanitaire du coc vite 19
certains se sont adaptés en ligne alors
première question j'ai débouché est ce
que vous espérez déjà atteindre cette
somme de 87 millions d'euros font ça va
être compliqué cette année on sait très
bien encore on s'attend à voir une
baisse conséquente
étant donné que les animations sur le
terrain ne peuvent pas avoir lieu
beaucoup d'animations ont été annulés et
ça représentait l'année dernière 37
millions d'euros à la collecte sur le
terrain donc on s'attend à avoir une
baisse d'environ 30 millions d'euros
sur les animations de terrain
alors qu'on va compenser peut-être un
petit peu avec les animations en ligne
mais on s'attend à avoir une baisse
conséquente dont 37 millions d animation
de terrain par exemple si vous en citer
quelques unes qu'on fait habituellement
ça peut être les lotos les soirées
dansantes les ventes de crêpes toutes
les animations en extérieur beaucoup
d'animations scolaires aussi n'ont pas
pu avoir lieu toutes les courses du
muscle voilà on a beaucoup de nos
organisateurs qui ont dû annuler leur
leurs animations ou bien les organiser
de façon différente mais avec un public
qui sera beaucoup moins important
beaucoup moins familiale que d'habitude
et qui sera pas le même
on imagine bien je dit tout à l'heure
que cette attente d'une maladie
neuromusculaire charcot marie tooth
qu'est ce que cela représente pour vous
justement ce week-end de mobilisation du
téléthon bah c'est un week-end des
sports c'est celle week-end ou famille
on attend beaucoup de la recherche
donc on est bornée à fond barton monde
et puis on est très reconnaissant très
reconnaissants des gens de tous les
organisateurs de tous les bénévoles de
tous les participants qui sont son
formidable sur le terrain je vous sens
ému forcément on comprend bien noté
spectateurs peuvent largement le
comprendre on va faire une petite pause
dans notre échange pour aller voir du
côté de guyancourt justement les
animations prévues pour ce téléthon 2020
alors de vente de repas sont organisées
l'une exotiques
organisé par l'association espérance foi
et amour et l'autre une vente de repas
asiatique cette fois-ci par jardin
passion partagent elles sont programmées
les deux prochains samedis de décembre
le menu est à 20 euros et les bénéfices
seront évidemment reversés à l'afm
téléthon
alors je lis ou chez est-ce que puis
nous expliquer ce que c'est que votre
maladie précisément c'est une maladie
neuromusculaire donc les
mes nerfs fonctionne mal en fait je ne
sais mon organisme ne fabrique pas la
protéine qui entoure la gaine des nerfs
donc c'est vraiment un fil électrique si
vous ôtez la protection la gaine du fil
électrique
l'information arrive mal et où n'arrive
pas à destination
c'est une maladie qui va créer beaucoup
de fatigue et beaucoup de faiblesse
musculaire des troubles de l'équilibré
des difficultés à la marche aidés des
formations au niveau des mains des pieds
essentiellement donc beaucoup de
difficultés au quotidien
rien d'insurmontable mais tout est plus
compliqué en fait oui c'est un petit peu
l'impact au quotidien sur votre vie ça
c'est un impact j'imagine oui oui oui
parce que la fatigue en fait ça se voit
pas mais c'est quelque chose qui est
toujours présent et en fait
en fait pour moi les actes du quotidien
c'est comme si je le faisais avec des
poids de 3 kg aux chevilles et aux
poignets en fait tout est plus compliqué
et à monter un escalier c'est plus
compliqué traverser une rue c'est
compliqué faire ses courses et compliqué
toutes et tous demandent à s'adapter
adapter un emploi du temps
voilà pour gérer la fatigue alors est-ce
que donc je rappelle que le téléthon
c'est la collecte de dons les
mobilisations c'est pour récolter de
l'argent pour faire des recherches
est ce qu'il ya des recherches faites
sur votre maladie en particulier il ya
plusieurs programmes en cours
financés par l'afm
alors pour l'instant on est juste au
stade des essais thérapeutiques en a pas
encore de médicaments mais le fait
qu'ils aient des traitements qu'ils
soient mis sur le marché dans des
d'autres maladies neuromusculaires ça
nous donne beaucoup d'espoir parce qu'en
fait si on avance dans une technologie
particulière ça va permettre d'aider
aussi dans nos pathologies à nous voilà
c'est enfin c'est un petit pas pour pour
tout le monde en fait
qui sait quand il ya un médicament de
mise sur le marché quoi et le téléthon
fait avant que ces recherches justement
mais c'est la fm les laboratoires qui
sont issus des dons récoltés par l'afm
donc le généthon qui est à evry qui
amène les recherches qui permettent de
mettre en place des essais
thérapeutiques donc déjà de soigner des
enfants par la thérapie génique on a des
médicaments de thérapie génique qui sont
actuellement en cours de fin des enfants
qui sont traités actuellement par
thérapie génique dans des pathologies
donc on espère que ça va être étendu à
de plus en plus de maladies puisqu'il ya
énormément de maladies qui sont
éligibles à ce type de traitement
d'accord on parle maintenant du côté de
villepreux vous disions fait le tour des
communes de saint quentin en yvelines
la ville organise deux jours
d'animations avec la crise sanitaire la
municipalité a choisi un programme
notamment en ligne donc justement pour à
cause de la crise sanitaire donc avec la
diffusion d'un court-métrage deux soeurs
et d'un échange sur facebook en direct
avec le réalisateur thomas payet qui est
d'ailleurs originaire de villepreux
donc ça c'est ce vendredi soir ce
vendredi 4 décembre
samedi 5 décembre au marché il y aura
les courses du téléthon et le soir une
soirée est organisée en visio sur zoom
et sur youtube sur le thème michael
jackson and friends et pour obtenir le
lien de la soirée il faut faire un don
sur le site de l'afm téléthon
julie boucher vous serez bientôt
coordinatrice du téléthon dans les
yvelines
alors les yvelines est qu'elle sera un
petit peu votre rôle est pourquoi ce
choix d'être coordinatrice du téléthon
alors en fait moi ça fait
longtemps que je fais partie de la
grande famille de l'afm en tant que
bénévole mais plutôt côté famille et
puis j'ai contacté daniel benquet
actuellement coordinateur pour les
yvelines est en lui proposant un coup de
main et il m'a dit écoute je cherche
quelqu'un pour prendre la suite est-ce
que tu accepterais et donc je dis bah
écoutes je t'accompagne cette année et
puis on voit ce que ça donne et puis on
verra pour passer le flambeau dans les
années à venir mais on fait une
transition ensemble voilà donc voilà
j'ai beaucoup à apprendre de daniel
parce que il est là depuis très très
longtemps depuis le début du téléthon
sur sur les yvelines donc il a
énormément de connaissances à
transmettre sur sur le fonctionnement du
téléthon et puis cette année ça a été
une année un peu particulière donc
compte tenu du du confinement et de la
crise sanitaire on n'a pas pu ou mettre
en place tout ce qu'on voulait donc
voilà on va faire ça sur plusieurs
années je pense pour pour passer le
flambeau sereinement merci juliusz et
d'avoir été avec nous sur ce plateau
on termine notre petit tour d'horizon
des animations prévues sur
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines à montigny le bretonneux c est
un programme sportif mais en ligne
toujours qui a été conçu sur quinze
jours soit jusqu'au 18 décembre vous
pouvez vous inscrire pour jouer aux
échecs ou encore au poker ou bien même
faire une initiation à l'aïkido et enfin
à coignières une collecte de dons est
organisée demain samedi 5 décembre sur
les parkings des différents centres
commerciaux de la ville
et je rappelle que vous pouvez faire un
don au 36 37
mais également sur le site dont point
telethon.fr
la secrétaire d'état en charge des
personnes handicapées sophie cluzel
était en visite au château de versailles
hier jeudi trois dessins un déplacement
dans le cadre de la journée
internationale des personnes handicapées
et qui a aussi pu lancer la 8e édition
de la semaine du handicap au château de
versailles
reportage à l'occasion de la journée
internationale des personnes handicapées
la secrétaire d'état sophie cluzel s'est
rendu au château de versailles jeudi 3
décembre une visite qui a été l'occasion
de constater que ce monument vieux de
près de 400 ans s'adapte pour se rendre
accessible j'étais justement avec la
fondation de la française des jeux qui a
justement financer un ascenseur très
très bien fait cachez donc il ne détruit
pas justement c'est cette cet
environnement classés et pour autant il
sert à tous bien sûr aux personnes
handicapées mais aux familles nombreuses
avec poussettes
donc on voit bien que quand on investit
100 l'accès à la différence on investit
pour tout le monde
bien sûr que c'est un défi mais c'est
possible nul n'est inaccessible comme
lieu surtout des lieux de culture aussi
important que le château de versailles
en plus de la visite la secrétaire
d'état a tenu à faire un focus
particulier sur la politique d'emploi
des personnes handicapées au sein du
château normalement l'obligation dans
post 6 % ici on est à près de 10%
donc ça veut dire une vraie politique rh
inclusif sur près de 50 métiers et ce
qui est formidable c'est que dans un
château classé
eh bien on arrive à faire de
l'accessibilité pour tous les publics
donc on qu'on ne me dise plus ce n'est
pas possible si quand ya une volonté
quand l intelligence collective pour
rendre accessible et cheminon compliqué
eh bien on fait tout simplement l'accès
à la culture pour tous cette visite
ministérielle a aussi été l'occasion
pour le château de versailles de lancer
sa huitième édition de la semaine du
handicap
compte tenu du contexte sanitaire les
animations se feront pour la plupart à
distance toutefois des visites contées
adaptés sont aussi organisées dans
l'actualité également l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines s'engage
encore plus dans l'agriculture locale et
les circuits courts
jeudi 3 décembre au soir élus et
partenaires ont fait un tour d'étape de
leur plan d'action voté l'année dernière
c'est la déclinaison du plan climat air
énergie territorial beltran au lion vice
président en charge des espaces verts et
de l'agriculture a dressé un constat
positif pour le territoire on les écoute
ces dernières années l'agriculteur a
complètement millvina commencé à évoluer
on comptait par exemple en 2000 2010 8
8% de notre surface agricole en
agriculture biologique
un an après donc en 2019 on en était à
14%
on a douze des trente quatre
exploitations qui interviennent à saint
quentin en yvelines qui se sont
orientées aujourd'hui en totalité ou en
partie au niveau de leur production vers
les circuits courts alimentaires comme
vous l'avez vu on note aussi qu'un tiers
des exploitants à moins de 40 ans et que
saint quentin en yvelines compte 10 amap
pardon 16 amap répartis sur dix des
douze communes et enfin l'actualité de
la semaine c'est justin brasier qui vous
la résume en 78 secondes
[Musique]
valéry giscard d'estaing est décédé
mercredi des suites de lakovic 19 à
l'âge de 94 ans un président réformateur
au pouvoir entre 1974 et 1981 il a
notamment instauré la majorité à 18 ans
légaliser les vg ou encore le divorce
par consentement mutuel le premier
ministre jean castex s'est rendu à
trappes dans l'entreprise connaît un
leader dans le secteur des ascenseurs
objectif aller à la rencontre des jeunes
sans formation pour promouvoir le plan
un jeune une solution une nouvelle
opération de dépistage massif a pris
place au vélodrome nationale des tests
antigénique accessible à tous pour
lutter contre la coved 19 l'accès était
sur rendez vous via l'application
d'octobre 2000 tests devaient être
réalisés la première étape d'allègement
des mesures du confinement a été
actionnée les commerces dits non
essentiels ont rouvert leurs portes
l'activité physique est désormais
autorisée dans un rayon de 20 km pour
une durée maximale de trois heures coup
d'envoi du projet rer vélo un réseau de
650 km de pistes cyclables en
ile-de-france pour circuler en toute
sécurité
le projet prévoit la réalisation de neuf
lignes dont 5 devrait être mise en
service d'ici 2025
coût total 500 millions d'euros
[Musique]
enfin comme chaque semaine un petit mot
de voile libinois louis burton remonte
encore au classement du vendée globe le
skipper originaire de rambouillet est
actuellement à la deuxième place juste
derrière charlie dalin le navigateur a
passé le cap de bonne espérance au sud
de l'afrique
à bord de son imoca bureau vallée 2
effet cap désormais sur l'australie
louis burton a enregistré une vidéo
cette semaine
il revient notamment sur le sauvetage de
kevin escoffier par jean le cam kevin
escoffier qui est d'ailleurs le cousin
par alliance de louis burton
on écoute sa réaction je pensais pour
kevin on a eu très peur
des angoisses tribunal hors du mali
bon
la société autour
tu as dû être l'enfer
j'ai beaucoup pensé à vous un grand
bravo bravo jean la classe j'ai vite a
assuré comme d'habitude voilà c'est cool
c'est une histoire qui se termine bien
e
prends soin de toi
de retrouver les siens
ce
content parce que c'était
c'est la mort
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi l'information revient
lundi à 18h dans le 7-8 journal présenté
par grégory canale et d'ici là je
souhaite une très bonne soirée et un
très bon week end
[Musique]